ah
a timeless theater of war a new vision
prepare to deploy to the Pacific the
team at dice are hard at work creating
an iconic World War two experience
releasing this fool with Chapter five of
battlefield 5 as the u.s. and Japan
enter the fight you'll clash across
several battlefields including a modern
take on an absolute classic
Iwo Jima since battlefield began the
Pacific Theater has been part of its DNA
now we're crafting the ultimate
reimagining of the conflict by capturing
real-life environments and using the
power of frostbite we're bringing you
the Pacific realized with today's
capabilities and technology take part in
the u.s. invasions as they're
unstoppable forces charged inland
towards unwavering Japanese defenses use
new amphibious units to pummel the war
ridden shores and an expanded arsenal to
bring your squad to victory
we have a lot more to share about the
Pacific and how it will evolve
battlefield 5 later in the year stay
tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
okay most importantly you went on like a
bunch of like research trips like let's
find out more about that oh let's set
that one in Tahiti yeah that's right I
know it's amazing how many people are
willing to make that extra effort to go
to Hawaii dan you were in Stockholm yeah
so it's quite quite impressive we really
appreciate the team putting in that work
oh yeah but obviously I mean this is the
big new the big new addition to
Battlefield 5 so going back nuclear war
in the Pacific I mean this is this is a
homecoming for Lars I mean not even team
itself but this jokes aside it's you
know having been with battlefield all
through the journey it's really where it
all started battle in 1942
you know the Pacific Theater and already
when we started to talk about this game
the journey through the Second World War
everyone came up and kind of when do go
to the Pacific so this is the time it
feels like a homecoming 1942 between
1943 we've been there before but this is
in a new way and I think I think the
great thing I mean we hear a lot from
the community and I know you know we
have these discussions you've got where
my US forces where's my Japanese army
and you know can you sit here in LA
today and tell everybody that it's come
in Chapter five you're gonna get those
things you're gonna see some familiar
places like Iwo Jima we've got two other
maps coming with that so three maps
coming with the initial package of the
Pacific and Chapter five some ones I
think that I think people are gonna be
really happy with what they're gonna see
and just saying some that you can hear
from the ping and the in the trailer
some iconic things as well Mike around
it's coming right we're living for the
ping so we wouldn't go to Iwo Jima
without kind of the weaponry and the
hardware so bringing tons of iconic
weapons gadgets and also after all its
battlefield so of course there will be a
new set of vehicles and and we want to
take that extra strap and kind of start
giving you the boats fulfilling that
sandbox of land air and sea and the team
has focused hard on capturing kind of
that invasion experience I mean it was
very much about island hopping during
the wars
capturing deviation experience and the
amphibious warfare so there's tons of
new stuff and a new gameplay to look
forward to and beautiful locations
destroy ignition Brian thank you both
very much for joining us so you've lost
track of all of these brand-new
Battlefield announcements I don't blame
you because honestly there was quite a
lot so I do you want to give us a little
bit of a recap there shreemant i'll
leave that on your capable shoulders
come back of the balcony if they yeah